[Music]
hi I'm a JavaScript developer and my
passion is building things for the web
so when it comes to building native
mobile apps javascript has always felt
like the best tool for the job either
via ionic cordova or react native but
flutter has blown my mind recently both
in terms of the developer experience and
the quality of the apps that it can
produce if you're a JavaScript developer
who's heard rumors about flutter and
looking to get acquainted this is the
video for you if you're new here like
and subscribe and you can grab the full
write-up and source code from fire ship
I know first we'll talk about the
trade-offs then we'll look at the
flutter project structure compared to
react native and ionic
then we'll compare the dart programming
language to JavaScript then we'll finish
up by cloning a couple of react native
components as flutter widgets flutter
may or may not be the right tool for the
job everything in life is a trade-off
and there are a couple of big trade-offs
with flutter right off the bat the first
one is the learning curve so if you're
already a web developer or JavaScript
developer you can basically just jump
right into an ionic or react native
project without any learning curve
another potential drawback is the size
of the community coding boot camps are
churning out new JavaScript developers
every day so it's a lot easier to source
talent for your project and the truth is
companies using hybrid frameworks are
generally doing so to save time and
money now while I said there's a
learning curve that learning curve is
pretty gentle this comment says it all
javascript is my wife dart is my
mistress but dart isn't ahead of time
compiled language so it brings something
else to the table performance its engine
is written in C++ and when you have to
make a lot of callbacks to the native
system it's just going to perform better
than a JavaScript bridge it can also
integrate existing native code it can do
hot reloads during development and it
has some of the best documentation that
I've seen for any framework period I'm
in the process of building my own
flutter app for fire ship IO and while
it's not a silver bullet that's just
going to make app development easy you
might be pleasantly surprised and
refreshed if you're a full-time j/s
developer let's go ahead and fade out
the music and start looking at some code
I want to start with just a baseline
comparison of the project structure to
react native and ionic the baseline app
that we have here is just three tabs at
the bottom that can toggle between three
different screens you're looking at the
one I built with flutter but react
native and ionic have their own
templates that you can just generate
with their CL is in a react native
project
building components and those components
combine these styles the templating and
the JavaScript logic in a single file
for each component generally speaking
you use NPM to manage your dependencies
of course and then we have about ten
different JavaScript files to get this
three tap layout working and it looks
almost just like a regular react app
with some special components for
rendering the UI on native and some
platform checking here and there at the
end of the video we'll actually build a
couple of react native components in
flutter now I'm opening up in ionic for
project and you'll see that we have
quite a few more files but that's mainly
because angular separates the templates
and the CSS into their own isolated
files I think this is a good way to
separate concerns but it can also be
pretty overwhelming if you're jumping
into this project for the first time
especially if you don't know angular and
there's a pretty long list of
dependencies that you'll have to learn
but because ionic for now uses web
components you'll be able to use it with
any framework that you want now when we
jump into our flutter project you'll see
right off the bat that it's far less
complex than the JavaScript counterparts
we just have a single file called main
dart which is the entry point to our app
and I was able to build this three tab
layout with only 45 lines of code there
was no import/export headaches and no
boilerplate if we want to run the app we
can do that directly from the command
line and there's no need to download a
special app from the App Store or to
debug in the browser and anytime you
make a change to your code you just
enter R on the command line and it will
hop reload the code and save the state
of the actual app itself react native
can do this also and it has a huge
impact on your development productivity
and when it comes to dependencies you
have this pub spec Yamma which is the
equivalent to a package.json you only
have one dependency right out of the
gate which is the flutter SDK and then
if you add anything else to this file it
will automatically update your
dependencies when you save so if you
like simplicity you might like flutter
but if you want to learn flutter that
means you have to learn a whole another
programming language dart but luckily it
shares a lot of the same conventions as
JavaScript so my goal in the next couple
minutes is to make you productive with
dart from the first keystroke let's look
at the syntax side-by-side with
typescript which will mostly just be
vanilla JavaScript the main entry point
for a dart app which is on the left is
the main function this is where your app
will start executing in JavaScript we
don't really have this concept but what
Apps comment like do is export a
function and then have that function be
called by the library consumer when you
declare a basic reassign humble variable
in dart you start with the type
annotation so if we have a string
variable
we'll type string then we can assign
that variable to a string value and then
reassign it later if we want and if we
want to log that value we can just call
print which is the equivalent to console
login Jas
now we can write the same code over here
in JavaScript which would use let
instead of the type annotation and if we
want to add a type we can append that to
the person variable we can also add
single assignment variables in
JavaScript which we can do with the
Const keyword so it's a cost per s'en
equals Jeff in dart we would instead use
the final keyword this is kind of
confusing because there's also a Const
keyword and dart but it works slightly
different it's more like calling object
freeze and JavaScript because it will
make the entire data structure and
mutable so in dart you would use Const
to make an array or a map completely
immutable meaning its properties or
elements can't be changed so dart has a
sound type system but it's also flexible
for example we can use the VAR keyword
to tell dart to implicitly figure out
the type so if you hate type annotations
everywhere or if you have a dynamic type
this can be a useful tool
and speaking of dynamic dart also has a
dynamic type which is similar to the any
type and type script this is most useful
when you have data coming from external
source and you don't really know what
the shape of that data is going to look
like so when you see the dynamic keyword
that basically just means we don't know
now let's switch gears and talk about
something that's especially important in
JavaScript and that's importing things
between files there's a lot of ways to
do this in JavaScript but we'll just go
to the es6 way will export a default
value which points to our Lang variable
and we could export multiple values from
this file if we put it inside of braces
now if we go back to the file that wants
to import this value we can simply
import it from that file this works fine
when you just need one thing but you
know as a JavaScript developer that this
gets harder as you need more and more
things so we rely on snippets and
barrels and stuff like that just to
manage the mental boilerplate of imports
and exports in dart we don't have to
worry about exporting anything if we
declare a variable in this Global's dart
file and then import it in the other
file it's going to be available by
default and because dart is strong typed
and the tooling so good we can just
start typing out the name of something
in this file and it will intellisense
autocomplete for us now let's take a
look at functions functions feel just
like they do in JavaScript - the
function keyword if we want to use type
annotations they come before the actual
name unlike typescript which comes after
the name you can also use anonymous
phone
arrow functions and higher-order
functions in this example here we have a
higher-order function call me which
takes a function as its argument and
then when we call it we use an anonymous
function with the arrow syntax just like
we would in JavaScript so functions will
feel just like they do in JavaScript
just with a smaller code footprint now I
realize I'm going pretty fast with these
code snippets so make sure to check out
the full article if you want to copy and
paste these to try them out on your own
the next thing we'll look at is
object-oriented programming
dart supports mixin based inheritance
which means that any given class will
only have one superclass but the class
body can be used in multiple classes so
you can do things like behavior based
composition in JavaScript classes are
more or less just syntactic sugar for
prototype one heritance
so they get kind of a bad reputation in
the JavaScript community but in any case
the syntax is very similar so we define
a class by using the class keyword and
then we can instantiate that class by
calling it with parentheses in
JavaScript we do the exact same thing
except we use the new keyword when
instantiating the class the new keywords
optional in dart and you'll be
instantiating a lot of objects and
flutters so this helps keep your code
very clean when we instantiate an
instance of a class we're creating an
object we need to tell our code how to
create that initial object which we do
with a constructor in vanilla JavaScript
to look like this we pass arguments to
the constructor and then initialize them
as values on the this context in
typescript we can do this in a little
more sugary way where we annotate our
input variables as private or public and
then they'll automatically be available
on this class in dart we have an even
cleaner way to construct an object by
just calling the class as a function in
addition dart has the concept of public
and private members everything is public
by default but if you want to make
something private to the library or
class just add an underscore to the
beginning of its name and dart has
another cool thing up its sleeve called
named constructors the one we just wrote
is the default but we can also add a
name constructor to provide different
initialization logic as needed we just
implement a method name on the class
name itself and now we have a different
constructor with whatever logic we want
there's a lot more we could cover here
but the actual definitions of methods
and properties on this class is exactly
the same as it is in JavaScript so we'll
just go ahead and leave it there the
next thing I want to cover is the dart
list which is equivalent to a JavaScript
array
we can create a list of integers by
starting with the type annotation and
then define it just like we would in
JavaScript and just like JavaScript the
list has a whole bunch of built-in
methods that we can use to manipulate it
and loop over it you'll find all your
old favorites like for each map and
reduce and you'll find a lot of other
ones that are implemented in third-party
libraries like lodash but my absolute
favorite one is just having the last
property I don't even want to admit how
many times I've googled how to get the
last element from an array in JavaScript
only to settle on this crappy code or
use something like a ray pop which also
is an ideal the next thing we'll look at
is the dart map which is the equivalent
to a JavaScript object or a JavaScript
map it kind of takes the best of both
worlds and just combines them into a
single data structure in JavaScript we
can create a plane object by wrapping
key value pairs and braces we can almost
do the same thing with a dart map but
the keys in that object will be strongly
typed this means you can use anything
for the key itself which could be a
class or a class instance or whatever
you want now you could also do this with
a javascript map there just
syntactically not as nice to work with
now the next thing we're going to look
at is asynchronous programming which is
one of the most important concepts to
know for JavaScript and flutter alike in
JavaScript we have promises and we can
create promises by writing async
functions that return some value by
default these will automatically return
a promise now in some other async
function we can await the value of this
promise which will pause the execution
of the function until that promise
returns some kind of value and if we
don't want to use async await we can use
then to capture the value when it's
resolved or catch if it results in an
error in dart we don't have promises but
instead futures luckily you don't have
to relearn everything you know about
async programming because a future works
exactly like a promise we can write an
async function which will return a
future by default and we can write
another function that awaits the result
value from that future if we have a
future we can call then or catch error
on it so the ergonomics are really no
different than promises now dart has a
stream data structure for handling
multiple asynchronous values vanilla
JavaScript doesn't have anything like
that right out of the box but a lot of
libraries provide them like rxjs and mob
x via observables so an rxjs for example
we can create an observable like this
and if we want to listen to the values
in it we call subscribe on it then we
pass subscribe
callback function to execute some code
whenever it emits a new value we can
follow a similar pattern in dart with
the stream object but we can actually
use this with async/await as well we can
use in a weight for loop to basically
loop over an object as it changes over
time this often results in much more
readable code compared to chaining a
bunch of callback functions together but
we can also subscribe to a stream just
like we would with an observable except
it's called listen so at this point
you're probably seeing a pattern the
dart is very similar to JavaScript in a
lot of ways but maybe a little smoother
around the edges so let's see how this
actually translates into building a
widget with flutter to do that I just
went to the react native Docs and
grabbed a couple of their examples the
first example shows how to apply Styles
in a way that can be merged so one style
can override the other in only the
properties that it wants to change on
the right we have the react native
component which was just copied directly
from the docs and then recreated in
flutter on the left in react native we
implement a render function that returns
a bunch of different components that
resemble HTML then to apply the styles
we have a style property then we can add
our Styles to an array and react will
apply those Styles from left to right
and flutter the overall structure looks
very similar but instead we are
instantiating objects and because
there's no new keyword it actually looks
like we're just calling functions and
all this happens inside the build method
which is the equivalent to render so
overall you should be able to see that
flutter took a lot of inspiration from
react so that's a very basic comparison
on a stateless widget or component but
the real value of these frameworks is
that they can react to changes in data
this time I'm grabbing the state example
from react native and will clone it in
flutter one of the main features of a
react component is that it has the set
state method that will rerender it when
called with state changes and flutter
has this exact same thing on what's
called a stateful widget and that's a
perfectly fine way to build your widgets
but what you'll find in both flutter and
react is that coin sets stay all the
time doesn't scale very well so you
pretty quickly have to implement
something like Redux for state
management and that's perfectly fine and
you can do that in flutter as well but
flutter also has these things called
builders which allow you to work with
asynchronous data sources and render the
UI automatically they're similar
conceptually to the async pipe in
angular basically you tell your UI to
listen to a stream and then rerender
different templates or widgets based on
whatever the value of that stream might
be I'm gonna go ahead and wrap things
there hopefully this gave you a general
idea of what flutter is all about I
never really expected to be writing dart
code on a regular basis but I am super
excited to be building the fire ship i/o
app with flutter thanks for watching and
I will talk to you soon
[Music]